The whole process of natural
selection is to some degree
dependent on the idea of
variation, that within any
population of a species, you
have some genetic variation.
So, for example, let's say I
have a bunch of-- well, this
is a circle species, and one guy
is that color, and then I
got a bunch more, maybe some
are that color-- oh, that's
the same color-- that one, and
that one, and that one.
And for whatever reason,
sometimes there are no
environmental factors that will
predispose one of these
guys to be able to survive and
reproduce over the other, but
every now and then, there might
be some environmental
factor, and it makes maybe, all
of a sudden, this guy more
fit to reproduce.
And so for whatever reason, this
guy is able to reproduce
more frequently and these
guys less frequently.
And some of them get killed,
or whatever, or eaten by
birds, or whatever, or they're
just not able to reproduce for
whatever reason, and then maybe
these guys are something
in between.
So over time, the frequency of
the different traits you see
in this population
will change.
And if they are drastic enough,
maybe these guys start
becoming dominant and start not
liking these guys, because
they're so different
or whatever else.
We could see a lot of
different reasons.
This could eventually turn
into a different species.
Now, the obvious question is
what leads to this variation?
In a population what leads to
this-- in fact, even in our
population, what leads to one
person having dirty blonde
hair, one person having brown
hair, one person having black
hair, and we have the spectrum
of skin complexions and
heights is pretty
much infinite.
What causes that?
And then one thing that I kind
of point to, we talked about
this a little bit in
the DNA video, is
this notion of mutations.
DNA, we learned, is just a
sequence of these bases.
So adenine, guanine, let's say
I've got some thymine going.
I have some more adenine,
some cytosine.
And that these code, if you have
enough of these in a row,
maybe you have a few hundred
or a few thousand of these,
these code for proteins or
they code for things that
control other proteins,
but maybe you have a
change in one of them.
Maybe this cytosine for whatever
reason becomes a
guanine randomly, or maybe these
got deleted, and that
would change the DNA.
But you could imagine, if I
went to someone's computer
code and just randomly started
changing letters and randomly
started inserting letters
without really knowing what
I'm doing, most of the time,
I'm going to break the
computer program.
Most of the time, the great
majority of the time, this is
going to go nowhere.
It'll either do nothing, for
example, if I go into
someone's computer program and
if I just add a couple of
spaces or something, that might
not change the computer
program, but if I start getting
rid of semicolons and
start changing numbers and all
that, it'll probably make the
computer program break.
So it'll either do nothing or
it'll actually kill the
organisms most of the time.
Mutations: sometimes, they might
make the actual cell
kind of run amok, and we'll do a
whole maybe series of videos
on cancer, and that itself
obviously would hurt the
organism as well as a whole,
although if it occurs after
the organism has reproduced, it
might not be something that
selects against the organism
and it also
wouldn't be passed on.
But anyway, I won't go
detailed into that.
But the whole point is that
mutations don't seem to be a
satisfying source
of variation.
They could be a source or kind
of contribute on the margin,
but there must be something more
profound than mutations
that's creating the diversity
even within, or maybe I should
call it the variation, even
within a population.
And the answer here is
really it's kind of
right in front of us.
It really addresses kind of one
of the most fundamental
things about biology, and it's
so fundamental that a lot of
people never even question
why it is the way it is.
And that is sexual
reproduction.
And when I mean sexual
reproduction, it's this notion
that you have, and pretty much
if you look at all organisms
that have nucleuses-- and we
call those eukaroytes.
Maybe I'll do a whole video on
eukaryotes versus prokaryotes,
but it's the notion that if you
look universally all the
way from plants-- not
universally, but if you look
at cells that have nucleuses,
they almost universally have
this phenomenon that you have
males and you have females.
In some organisms, an organism
can be both a male and a
female, but the common idea
here is that all organisms
kind of produce versions of
their genetic material that
mix with other organisms'
version of
their genetic material.
If mutations were the only
source of variation, then I
could just bud off other Sals.
Maybe just other Sals would just
bud off from me, and then
randomly one Sal might be a
little bit different and
whatever else.
But that would, as we already
talked about, most of the
time, we would have very little
change, very little
variation, and whatever
variation does occur because
of any kind of noise being
introduced into this kind of
budding process where I just
replicate myself identically,
most of the time it'll
be negative.
Most of the time, it'll
break the organism.
Now, when you have sexual
reproduction, what happens?
Well, you keep mixing and
matching every possible
combination of DNA in a kind
of species pool of DNA.
So let me make this a little
bit more concrete for you.
So let me erase this horrible
drawing I just did.
So we all have-- let me stick
to humans because
that's what we are.
We have 23 pairs of chromosomes,
and in each pair,
we have one chromosome from our
mother and one chromosome
from our father.
So let me draw that.
So I'll draw my father's
chromosomes in blue.
So I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15--
I'm running out of space.
Let me do more here-- 16, 17,
18, 19, 20, 21, 22, and then
I'll throw another one
here that looks
a little bit different.
I'll throw one here that looks
like a Y, and we'll talk more
about the X's and the
Y chromosomes.
Then I have 23 chromosomes
from my mother.
And not to be stereotypical,
but maybe I'll do that in a
more feminine color.
Let's see, so I have 23
chromosomes from my mother.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17,
18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23.
So what's going on here?
I have 23 from my mother.
I have 23 from my father.
Now, each of these chromosomes,
and I made them
right next to each other.
So let me zoom in on
one pair of these.
So let's say we look at
chromosome number-- I'll just
call this chromosome number 3.
So let me zoom in on chromosome
number 3.
I have one from my mother
right here.
Actually, maybe I'll
do it this way.
Remember, chromosome is just a
big-- if you take the DNA, the
DNA just keeps wrapping around,
and it actually wraps
around all these proteins, and
it creates this structure, but
it's just a big-- when you see
it like that, you're like, oh,
maybe the DNA-- no, but this
could have millions of base
pair, so maybe it'll look
something like that.
It's a densely wrapped version
of-- well, it's a long string
of DNA, and when it's normally
drawn like this, which is not
always the way it is, and we'll
talk more about that,
they draw it as densely
packed like that.
So let's say that's
from my mother and
that's from my father.
Now, let's call this
chromosome 3.
They're both chromosome 3.
And what the idea here is that
I'm getting different traits
from my father and
from my mother.
And I'm doing a gross
oversimplification here, but
this is really just to
give you the idea of
what's going on.
This chromosome 3, maybe
it contains this
trait for hair color.
And maybe my father had-- and
I'll use my actual example.
My father had very
straight hair.
So someplace on this chromosome,
there's a gene for
hair straightness.
Let's say it's a little
thing right there.
And remember, that gene could
be thousands of base pairs,
but let's say this is
hair straightness.
So my father's version of that
gene, he had the allele for
straightness.
And remember, an allele is just
a version of a gene, so
I'll call it the allele straight
for straight hair.
Now, this other chromosome that
my mother gave me, this
essentially, and there are
exceptions, but for the most
part, it codes for the same
genes, and that's why I put
them next to each other.
So this will also have the gene
for hair straightness or
curlyness, but my mom
does happen to
actually have curly hair.
So she has the gene right
there for curly hair.
The version of the gene
here is allele curly.
The gene just says, look, this
is the gene for whether or not
your hair is curly.
Each version of the gene
is called an allele.
Allele curly.
Now, when I got both of these in
my body or in my cells, and
this is in every cell of my
body, every cell of my body
except for, and we'll talk in
a few seconds about my germ
cells, but every cells other
than the ones that I use for
reproduction have this complete
set of chromosomes in
it, which I find amazing.
But only certain chromosomes--
for example, these genes will
be completely useless in my
fingernails, because all of a
sudden, the straight and the
curly don't matter that much.
And I'm simplifying.
Maybe they will on some
other dimension.
But let's say for simplicity,
they won't
matter in certain places.
So certain genes are expressed
in certain parts of the body,
but every one of your body
cells, and we call those
somatic cells, and we'll
separate those from the sex
sells or the germs that we'll
talk about later.
So this is my body cells.
So this is the great majority
of your cells, and this is
opposed to your germ cells.
And the germ cells-- I'll just
write it here, just so you get
a clear-- for a male, that's
the sperm cells, and for
female that's the egg
cells, or the ova.
But most of my cells have a
complete collection of these,
and what I want to give you
the idea is that for every
trait, I essentially have two
versions: one from my mother
and one from my father.
Now, these right here are called
homologous chromosomes.
What that means is every time
you see this prefix homologous
or if you see like Homo sapiens
or even the word
homosexual or homogeneous,
it means same, right?
You see that all the time.
So homologous means that they're
almost the same.
They're coding for the most part
the same set of genes,
but they're not identical.
They actually might code for
slightly different versions of
the same gene.
So depending on what versions
I get, what is actually
expressed for me, so my
genotype-- let me introduce
another word, and
I'm overwhelming
you with words here.
So my genotype is exactly what
alleles I have, what versions
of the gene.
So I got like the fifth version
of the curly allele.
There could be multiple versions
of the curly allele
in our gene pool.
And maybe I got some version
of the straight allele.
That is my genotype.
My phenotype is what my hair
really looks like.
So, for example, two people
could have different genotypes
with the same-- they might
code for hair that looks
pretty much the same,
so it might have a
very similar phenotype.
So one phenotype can be
represented by multiple genotypes.
So that's just one thing to
think about, and we'll talk a
lot about that in the future,
but I just wanted to introduce
you to that there.
Now, I entered this whole
discussion because I wanted to
talk about variation.
So how does variation happen?
Well, what's going to happen
when I-- well, let
me put it this way.
What's going to happen
when I reproduce?
And I have. I have a son.
Well, my contribution to my son
is going to be a random
collection of half
of these genes.
For each homologous pair, I'm
either going to contribute the
one that I got from my mother or
the one that I got from my
father, right?
So let's say that the sperm cell
that went on to fertilize
my wife's egg, let's say it
happened to have that one,
that one, or I could
just pick one from
each of these 23 sets.
And you say, well, how many
combinations are there?
Well, for every set, I could
pick one of the two homologous
chromosomes, and I'm going
to do that 23 times.
2 times 2 times 2, so that's
2 to the twenty third.
So 2 to the 23 different
versions that I can contribute
to any son or daughter that I
might have. We'll talk about
how that happens when we talk
about meiosis or mitosis, that
when I generate my sperm cells,
sperm cells essentially
takes one-- instead of having
23 pairs of chromosomes in
sperm, you only have
23 chromosomes.
So, for example, I'll take one
from each of those, and
through the process of meiosis,
which we'll go into,
I'll generate a bunch
of sperm cells.
And each sperm cell will have
one from each of these pairs,
one version from each
of those pairs.
So maybe for this chromosome I
get it from my dad, from the
next chromosome, I get
it from my mom.
Then I donate a couple more
from-- I should've drawn them
next to each other.
I donate a couple more
from my mom.
Then for chromosome number 5,
it comes from my dad, and so
on and so forth.
But there's 2 to the
twenty-third combinations
here, because there
are 23 pairs that
I'm collecting from.
Now, my wife's egg is going to
have the same situation.
There are 2 to the 23 different
combinations of DNA
that she can contribute just
based on which of the
homologous pairs she
will contribute.
So the possible combinations
that just one couple can
produce, and I'm using my life
as an example, but this
applies to everything.
This applies to every species
that experiences sexual
reproduction.
So if I can give 2 to
twenty-third combinations of
DNA and my wife can give 2 to
the 23 combinations of DNA,
then we can produce 2 to the
forty-sixth combinations.
Now, just to give an idea of how
large of a number this is,
this is roughly 12,000 times the
number of human beings on
the planet today.
So there's a huge amount of
variation that even one couple
can produce.
And if you thought that even
that isn't enough, it turns
out that amongst these
homologous pairs, and we'll
talk about when this happens in
meiosis, you can actually
have DNA recombination.
And all that means is when these
homologous pairs during
meiosis line up near each other,
you can have this thing
called crossover, where all of
this DNA here crosses over and
touches over here, and all
this DNA crosses over and
touches over there.
So all of this goes there and
all of this goes there.
What you end up with after the
crossover is that one DNA, the
one that came from my mom, or
that I thought came from my
mom, now has a chunk that came
from my dad, and the chunk
that came from my dad, now has a
chunk that came from my mom.
Let me do that in
the right color.
It came from my mom like that.
And so that even increases the
amount of variety even more.
So you can almost now, instead
of talking about the different
chromosomes that you're
contributing where the
chromosomes are each of these
collections of DNA, you're now
talking about-- you can almost
go to the different
combinations at the gene level,
and now you can think
about it in almost infinite
form of variation.
You can think about all of the
variation that might emerge
when you start mixing and
matching different versions of
the same gene in a population.
And you don't just
look at one gene.
I mean, the reality is that
genes by themselves very
seldom code for a specific-- you
can very seldom look for
one gene and say, oh, that is
brown hair, or look for one
gene and say, oh, that's
intelligence, or that is how
likable someone is.
It's usually a whole set of
genes interacting in an
incredibly complicated way.
You know, hair might be coded
for by this whole set of genes
on multiple chromosomes and
this might be coded for a
whole set of genes on multiple
chromosomes.
And so then you can start
thinking about all of the
different combinations.
And then all of a sudden, maybe
some combination that
never existed before all of a
sudden emerges, and that's
very successful.
But I'll leave you to think
about it because maybe that
combination might be passed on,
or it may not be passed on
because of this recombination.
But we'll talk more about
that in the future.
But I wanted to introduce this
idea of sexual reproduction to
you, because this really is the
main source of variation
within a population.
To me, it's kind of a
philosophical idea, because we
almost take the idea of having
males and females for granted
because it's this
universal idea.
But I did a little reading on
it, and it turns out that this
actually only emerged about 1.4
billion years ago, that
this is almost a useful trait,
because once you introduce
this level of variation, the
natural selection can start--
you can kind of say that when
you have this more powerful
form of variation than just pure
mutations, and maybe you
might have some primitive form
of crossover before, but now
that you have this sexual
reproduction and you have this
variation, natural selection
can occur in a
more efficient way.
So that species that were able
to reproduce and essentially
recombine their DNA and mix and
match it in this way were
able to produce more variety and
were able to essentially
be selected for their
environment in a more
efficient way so they started
to essentially outnumber the
ones that couldn't, so it
became a kind of very
universal trait.
But you could have imagined a
world, and there are science
fiction books written about
this, where you have three
genders, where you have gender
one, two, three.
You could have 10 genders.
It just happens to be that on
Earth, this notion of having
two genders turned out to be a
very efficient and stable way
of introducing variation
into a population.
So, hopefully, you found
that interesting.
In the next video, I'll go more
into the detail of how
exactly meiosis and
mitosis works.